Primrose Everdeen very well come on up  just trying to win babe you can't maybe  I can I am smart you know you can find  exactly  protect you how do you find shelter give  me a chance to wake up sweetheart this  mentoring is very taxing stuff  pass the marmalade why do you think we  have a winner what do you mean I mean  why do we have a winner I mean if we  just wanted to intimidate the district's  why not round up 24 of them at random  and execute them all at once  well I'll tell you what Peter you go out  there and you win this thing and when  you get home she'll have to go out with  you right folks I don't want to be  another piece in their game you know you  mean you won't tell anyone no yeah yeah  I'm sure I would just like anybody else  in the time came 'let  and I couldn't saying something then  come here please  there's a slight rule change the  previous revision allowing for two  Victor's from the same district has been  revoked the only one picture may be  crowned good luck